on this episode I am the legendary Bob
right
[Music]
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 195 on the ask gary vee
show and we have a guest yeah mr. right
Bob why don't you tell the Vayner nation
why don't I give you 60 to 90 seconds
here to create a little context your
career book kind of the things that
you're involved with obviously yeah
actually know what sort of India India
with create curated a show here today by
the way let me jump in here for a second
sorry Bob for a second we were trying to
do more thematic shows we obviously had
guests the other day for influencer
marketing we've got three or four more
in the bucket and this falls into that
series so why don't you tell the Vayner
nation because they like you very much
what we're doing here where the
questions are coming from Twitter using
a very gary tactic getting out there
into the trenches and searching for
questions and ask people to film their
questions in the videos and Bob I think
throwing you to you under that framework
maybe a little bit about your
professional career maybe how you fit
within the context of that world a
little bit sure you know maybe the
unique angle I can talk about is that we
formed Autism Speaks while I was working
as the CEO of NBC Universal and it when
we we did all that kind of work while I
was still working and that surprises
some people but you know you can do more
than one thing at the same time I've
been I was CEO for the 22 years at that
point in time and it did it caused us to
have to really be very focused on how we
used our time so that I wasn't
interrupting my work or other people's
work to do this and I brought in people
for board members or established people
in the New York community that had some
interest in it or had a relationship
with a person in their family or some
friend that one of the people didn't
have that but he did have a history with
dyslexia and he knew how difficult it
was for children to learn so we we put
this whole organization to
gather in nineteen in 2004 and I made a
determination that we wanted to run this
like a business and so I said we're
going to have all of our financials are
going to be audited we're going to file
at every single state in the United
States you have to file twice you have
to file for to raise money we have to
file to operate in there and we did all
these things in a very businessí way so
that we would we could get out and when
we at least started in 2005 we could get
going and we could we could act anywhere
in the country and then the other thing
I looked at is I look for other
organizations that we're dealing with
children or adults with autism we wanted
to deal with children because it's more
difficult to deal with adults because
their their their their resources are
are not as attractive and children we
knew that you could help them and you
know if you miss all that helping as an
adult you're losing an awful lot so we
wanted to start with people that I know
we could we can we can help like my
grandson who's the reason why he's 14
years old by the way and he's he's not
going to be working for Google anytime
soon he has very limited communication
ability I'd say on a scale of one to ten
he's a three or a four perhaps and he
can only talk when he's heavily prompted
so he needs people with him all the time
he can't be left alone because you just
don't know what he'll do he doesn't
communicate and give you the signals as
to what his next idea is going to be you
know he could you know it's that sort of
a thing so but anyway we did all this
and then we looked at three
organizations and I went out and met
with these parent organizations they're
all kind of exhausted that's what
happens to not-for-profits especially
disease-related once people work very
very hard and then all of a sudden they
they usually their their view is they
want to do a lot of science they want to
do a lot of things they make a lot of
commitments but they get tired of
raising money and it gets tired it's
tiring and and pretty soon they they've
got debt or they're just do you feel the
business DNA of being a CEO of one of
the biggest companies in the world for
so long was a massive advantage in
running that Autism Speaks organization
with that DNA be
you felt the vulnerabilities and
organizations that have been run in a
political bureaucratic more kind of
corporate less entrepreneurial
environment absolutely and I but I'd
also say that any anybody that has
business experience it should not forget
that business experience going into a
not-for-profit you you you you build up
skills and you build up ability to
manage people to deal with you you don't
want to lose that because you're not
well it's one of my biggest arguments I
L it to my audience a lot of people in
start-up culture that's so many venture
capitalists even though they've built
businesses she or he has built a
business in the past they start giving
advice to these startups that are more
predicated on raising finances than
actually building a business yeah so I
think I think there's a huge parallel
but before we go into more of the
nonprofit and talk a little bit more
about Autism Speaks I want to I want to
respect the audience which I know is a
very heavy business organized audience
and I think some would find it quite
fascinating on how you made the rise to
such a prestigious CEO job so for kicks
and giggles give me 60 seconds on where
you were born what kind of kid you were
what then happened and then what was the
transition of the how did your career go
I grew up in the New York area on Long
on Long Island a Jets Jets fan yes I did
well I long I was on Long Island and I I
wanted my my goal in life is I wanted to
be Edward Bennett Williams which at the
time was America's most famous lawyer
courtroom lawyer and and he he had all
of the toughest cases and all of these
remarkable things and I I went to high
school in Long Island I went to college
and I went to law school and I and I was
I was married I'm married to Suzanne
right we've been together for 50 years
and 48 years married and by the way she
unfortunately in October 29th
last year's diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer and so we're really having a
struggle right now in that in that
respect so I mean now I'm right back
into the the not-for-profit issue and
now I'm dealing with my own trying to
trying to develop that
medicine based on her tumor but you know
it never ends you just kind of keep
learning
anyway I I did a bunch of different
things and I ended up having gone
through the Virginia Bar the New York
Bar the Massachusetts Bar and Lee in the
New Jersey bar when the Wonder wasn't
scaring to register in every state for
autism she basically did it in the law
no it wasn't it wasn't scary at all and
so I was a pretty good lawyer and I did
a lot and I long I was in private
practice for five and a half years I and
I got recruited to to Pittsfield
Massachusetts to work for Jack Welsh and
they had the fastest growing businesses
in in GE at that time in the 1970s early
70s and I came in as a lawyer and I very
quickly transferred I moved into
business on a law background was
fantastic it worked just like I'm saying
business background works in our buddy
law background works in business and I
just kept pure meeting on what I knew
and I got a chance yeah you have to take
chances
we moved 11 times before I was 40
Suzanne and I and three kids and people
don't do that no I saw a statistic the
other day that says it did since 1990
only 10% of people move out move a
couple of times and it's remarkable I
moved 11 times and and but that was all
necessary for me one of the things that
I learned early is if I wanted to be
successful and I was ambitious and I was
ambitious then I needed to take full
responsibility for my own career and I
could not there's no excuses
all the excuses have to be you it's if
it's a rainy day that's not an excuse if
I got a bad but the bad person I'm
working for you should have get out of
it you shouldn't work there it the fact
that I got sick is that's not an excuse
not you once you know that I mentally
decided six years ago to not get sick
again and I haven't I know you that
sounds strange I know that I have a big
belief that we don't understand the
brain and it's I don't like saying it
out loud I kind of threw it at you cuz
it because I when when I see when I hear
myself even saying and I'm like who's
cuckoo bird but I totally I totally but
I'm smiling and I'm sure a lot of the
audience is smiling right now because
maybe I throw a couple more curse words
into the rant that you just had but it
is absolutely the same exact listen the
market is the market is the market they
don't care about your headaches
it is what it is and if you if it
doesn't work out you have to start over
again or you have to start you have to
go someplace else do you feel do you
feel that that that experience as a
businessman an entrepreneur do you feel
like that gave you the intestinal
fortitude to be able to deal with life's
challenges as they've come in your
family life I do
I absolutely do we faced it we accepted
a lot of challenges so I and you know
some of them were really difficult to
overcome but that was what I wanted to
do so it's ironic yet you brought it up
staying well I I'm in the position right
now where I can't get sick right I can't
get sick because my wife is needs me and
she is desperately sick and there can't
be two of a sick so I have to do
everything right now and make sure I do
not get sick and that's that's the like
my number one issue that I'm facing in
this particular situation yes but anyway
we did we did a lot of different things
and we I had a chance I raised my hand
there was General Electric was trying to
the the Cox family an old-line family in
Atlanta had Cox Communications still
alive big big company they wanted to
sell part of their business I worked my
way down to become the president of the
company and the cable business was what
I was focused now it was brand new at
that time I thought it's going to be
really exciting and I went down there I
gave up all my stuff with a lot of my
friends real quick here who are watching
as I yell about why snapchat or mobile
devices or other things are gonna be
good why don't you give us a little bit
of a history lesson it's been run a
little bit longer than most episodes I'm
take full advantage of having you here
so tell all the youngsters these twenty
thirty year olds who are watching right
now or even 40 year olds who record an
interesting generation of non innovation
on what the people of the world in in
early eighty said about this cable thing
and it's in
the establishment what was the
establishments point of view on HBO on
cable on these cockamamie and things
that were above channel 13 it's a little
ironic it reminds me of the Trump thing
the the people loved it
businesspeople hated it and the
institutions didn't like it at all
and everybody wanted to stay where they
were with a three channel 3 channel
universe and and and that was good
enough and cable was was opening up
these other doors and people liked it
the customers liked it
yes but the institutions didn't like it
the institutions that had something to
lose institutions that were lending
money they didn't like it the investors
were very worried about it the people
that were in use did you understand that
36 channels was gonna be a good thing
that there was good about that that was
going to be successful did you believe
the ESPN's the MTV's at that point in
your career did you say okay these in
the way that I look at a snapchat or
musically and I say what you just said
and they year me say it it's not that
I'm saying this 150 million people are
downloading it and using it each month
I'm not making any predictions the data
is there did you see that well but
that's what that's exactly where we felt
now with 30 tweet when I was came in it
was only 12 13 channels and 36 was a big
jump we had the biggest cable system in
the country in San Diego and that was 36
that was a big deal and but we and the
people say silly things like how are you
gonna fill all that programming yeah and
will we actually yeah yes and and we but
that gave us a chance to try to produce
right fill that programming ourselves
and that was not something cable
operators did at that time they they
they hung wires and they split the boxes
in and then they ran there is that word
Turner did some smart yes no ring Ted
Turner never was a cable operator he was
a producer that's exactly right yeah he
was on the other side we were on the
side of the cable operator we were one
of the first systems to to put CNN on we
were one of his first customers but he
was never he never wanted the wire
business that's right and but he was a
he just was a visionary that had the
energy to force through his thoughts
regardless of how difficult it was gonna
be and I admired that we lived in
Atlanta that's where he looked so us but
so we got into that and the brain stunk
at this point
the Braves the Atlanta Braves they were
terrible yeah
do you find that to be intriguing fun
fact well I I remember going a lot of
games and rain don't see me was always
raining and I was sitting out there and
for an hour and a half in the rain
alright India let's get into a question
because I have a feeling I'm gonna just
like milk this into a four-hour video
hey Gary hey Cruz first where I'm also
absolutely loved the podcast secondly I
absolutely love this book
this is bestseller my name is Jerome
Hardaway I am a head geek in charge for
vets who code also known as frag girl
formerly United States Air Force what we
do here is that we teach veterans how to
program a hundred percent online at zero
cost to the veteran by utilizing a
pragmatic approach and focusing on one
language and problem start with that
language our guys and girls of the Armed
Forces are focused more on solving
problems and thinking like a programmer
as opposed to learning how to do the
same procedures in multiple languages
thanks to this we've been able to help
75 veterans gain jobs in a software
technology sector totally and to 3.2
million dollars for the salaries my
question to you Gary B is how do we get
into new communities that are tech rich
and talent rich and be able to build
relationships with those communities
even though we are not natively there
such as New Orleans or Boulder Colorado
thank you and thank you for supporting
veterans and thank you for supporting
investment co political help go ahead
political help that's a very good story
you're gonna you're going to need some
governmental assistance I hate to say
that because it's at the same time you
can raise money you can raise money but
you can raise money privately but your
kit your argument for what you're doing
has a lot of political clout and if you
go down and if you're in Louisiana and
you want to go into New Orleans there's
there's there's enough politicians down
there that would see this is an
opportunity to make themselves look up
to make themselves look good and do
something in the community I think it
you you have a good political handle
there to use and by the way once you
start raising money from with the
politics you'll get you get
individual you'll get other people
wanting to join the join the program
that's really this is what it's a
good-sounding
this is a good sounding situation this
is why this shows so fun when you have
two people that can give advice because
they come from such different angles and
I think that's incredible good advice I
would also say my friend that one of you
know getting in front of the tech
companies who are gonna hire your
developers when you're not in Silicon
Valley you're not in Boulder is actually
stunningly easy
it's called grit like you know you can
you can spam people I'm sure you've had
people through your career that have in
your career probably sent you later
letters and faxes and now emails I've
been in my professional career it's been
mainly email where no emailing every day
like Gary I need to see 50 minutes I
need to get to you I need to get to you
so you don't want to get into stalker
land and be inappropriate but if you
want to email slack if you want to email
Facebook if you want to email you burr
or Airbnb these companies are becoming
bigger by the moment - and all are also
looking to have relationships no
different than a politician that they
can put on their website or put in a
press release while they're getting
yelled at for setting up in Ireland and
not paying taxes they can throw this
kind of thing and you're right I mean
your narrative and we're going about to
hear some more but that nobody's ever
ever in the history of America going to
publicly say I'm not that into the
veterans no there's zero
there's people will disagree on many
things but not that one and so I would
say perseverance of reaching out to the
companies in Boulder Silicon Valley New
York and and trying different tactics
and also using Twitter search and
engaging with them because that's the
one cocktail party of the Internet where
there's permission for you to create a
relationship those are two tactical
things that I would do the other thing
to do would be to try to try to get
another like another location somebody
working with you in the tech more tech
sensitive areas it you know not
necessarily Silicon Valley but certainly
New York or Boston so that you can you
can take this and have developed some
like yourself down there now you've got
three groups out there and then now
that's where you're going to be able to
spread and job opportunities may be
coming back both ways yeah there's a lot
of ways to deploy kind of remote you
know teams especially around an issue
like this because so many fan
he's affected by and so many people just
I'm not affected by but I'm passionate
about I've been involved in it so I
think there's there's a lot of tactics
there India this is your dad India this
is very very exciting
your dad has made the show hello garyvee
love the show please don't stop
producing it I watch every episode a
question from the New World Symphony in
Miami Beach
our stability really depends on having a
group of core donors who give
continuously year after year after year
their generosity is essential to our
sustainability so we know how to do this
with the old-fashioned ways using snail
mail and email but not as one do this
with social media thanks in advance for
your answer by now is he dealing with
vets or do you like my kind of music
I do but it's thought that that's always
a tough one to raise money with right
because it's a you know it's it's always
a it's more nice to have versus the kind
of heavy stuff that we've been talking
about in the beginning or even even the
vets um okay so look a couple things
that's a big place there's a lot of
music down there so that's it should be
able to be do that do that well weird
interesting part of his question that I
find fascinating he's also very
good-looking man India which makes no
sense is that I never sew vaynermedia my
company and I'm curious to hear in your
company is back to business
always dictating my nonprofit my family
life the structure that's the thesis
when I started this client service
business the thought of letting a client
be too big of a percentage of my overall
revenue I was visceral to I even turned
down some opportunities because I didn't
even want to open Pandora's Box yeah I
would tell you the thing that scares me
there is having any organization that
relies and you've seen us a lot at the
levels you've played at one to three
people being so passionate that they're
driving so much of it men think
something could change a life event can
change where something else starts
taking attention and we're sitting right
here in a real-life example so I have
that problem myself with our with our
Watson speaks because Suzanne and I have
raised so much of the money and we have
been so much of the infrastructure that
we provided and everything that pulling
back is
there's a I can see there's a gap there
yeah and I think gotta get emotional
guilt for you right yeah well yeah yeah
just you know we built this and now you
guys have got to run it and they're
saying well we don't have you so you
know so I think the answer is scream you
know this is funny to have you on the
show your daughter's part of this
ecosystem I think you need to create
content whatever was compelling in male
form that got people to say I want to
call and have a coffee and find out more
about this you need to create the videos
and pictures that can do that in a
social media environment but here's some
good news you can target people of a
certain wealth and demo and location on
Facebook that can be very efficient and
is better data than the historic snail
mail data and and create that listen
there's a lovely gal that I know knows a
thing or two about this that you can I
don't want you hogging up any more time
because you can chat to your lovely
daughter about this she knows the gig so
let's move on India hi Gary
first I want to thank you for your
overnight sensation video all your stuff
is great but the overnight sensation
video when I get discouraged I watch it
and it kicks my ass thank you
the nonprofit sector is broken money
controls everything and for the
nonprofit sector to change and there
hasn't been a unique idea a brilliant
idea a disruptive idea and so so long it
needs to change and one of the examples
that I like to use is coffee kiosk
here's a coffee kiosk at YouTube and
Google there are almost every 150 feet
there Tom in it most startups you got
free yogurt and free milk and free Red
Bull and all kinds of free stuff here is
our coffee kiosk and I'm CMO of a large
nonprofit upstate New York and it's not
that we don't care any less about our
employees it's there's no funding
there's no funding for even free coffee
so the problem is the top and how do we
change that how do we get funders to
have a start-up mentality if you look at
the startup world you know Twitter uber
Airbnb these are ideas that might be
considered radical different disruptive
but somebody funded them and they funded
free coffee along with it we are not
going to see change in the nonprofit
sector until the funding streams change
that empower us to do the work how can
those of us in the nonprofit sector that
care how can we explain that how can we
get that change how can this top-down
change come into the nonprofit sector
don't take your chatter this one the
answer the answer to that is you've got
to be blunt you've got to go out and
find some angels some people that that
you have reason to believe are
interested in your not-for-profit and
have some funds have some some ability
maybe they have a store maybe they have
some money or something and you have to
get them and you have to be frank with
them and do it just as what you're
saying we're trying to do all these
things we've got all these people
volunteering but we need we need some
startup money here we need what we need
some angel to help us get through this
until we can have a larger thing and I
think if if you beat around the bush
with people they'll say well I'll give
you a small gift us I mean no no I need
to I need I need I really need your help
big help I got something to add on this
you mentioned uber Airbnb and Twitter
these are the top point zero one percent
of startups I know many startups this
startup my company started in the
conference wing of another company and I
guess we stole their free coffee and
things of that nature but the
interesting thing is Robin Hood and many
other organizations have a lot of money
a lot of money my biggest problem is
there's a lot of NGOs that I know and
I'm a lot of money and are wasting it or
not deploying enough of percentage
against the right thing so I think we
need to be a little bit careful here
there's thousands of startups that don't
have free coffee you're also talking
about people being incentivized by
capitalism the reason people write
checks to Google and uber and Airbnb is
because they want to make money back and
think you have to play the reverse game
in NGO which is much like the narrative
of your life and I've always known since
I was a young man because I always
believed I'd be successful that the
things that would capture my attention
though I'd become very involved in
charity water and I'd become very
involved in pencils of promise and
through Matt Higgins have been involved
with you guys and done stuff here for
Vayner with for you guys as well with
Autism Speaks I'm very aware I know with
all that being said that the things that
get the most of my attention will be the
things that affect me you know now I can
finally say it because very recently my
brother announced my partner in this
company vaynermedia that he's gonna be
leaving in a month because he has
Crohn's disease and he doesn't and you
know the pressure of it all is the one
thing and he just wants to be proactive
luckily everything's okay but he's just
projecting and being smart that is
something that's pulling at my heart in
the same way that my money investing in
a company pulls at my wallet Crohn's is
gonna pull in my heart because it
affects me you need to go out and find
the things that you're solving for who
are the five hundred five thousand
wealthiest that's the truth people that
are affected by the issue because your
conversion rate is gonna be better and I
I don't accept and I love you and thank
you for watching the show but I do not
accept this notion that you're gonna
compare yourself to the five or six
biggest Internet companies in the world
where I can take this camera with Stefan
right now and walk down the street and
show you real shitty offices from
startups that didn't get that funding
and they're grinding and guess what
Google and I was at Twitter I was at
Twitter when there was 11 people in that
office it looked like crap after they
won it looked nicer Google tried to sell
their company for a couple hundred
thousand dollars to Yahoo their office
wasn't amazing at the time so we need to
be careful of how we contextualize
ourselves as well India Kim oh our Kim
Kim I love Kim hi Gary I here's my
question for you I am on the board of an
organization in New York it's a
nonprofit called art connects New York
and
we work with local curators and artists
to do permanent art installations in
social service agencies all around New
York City it's an amazing organization
we have partnered with hundreds of
artists and dozens of dozens of
organizations but it's also super niche
and so we are working really hard to
broaden the base of people who are
interested in art connects and
ultimately will help donate to the cause
but with such an each club and then we
have one and a half full-time employees
who work for the organization they do
everything from coordinating the
installations to fundraising we are
super strapped and so we're looking for
some ways that we can quickly gain
momentum to broaden interest in the
organization knowing that we have very
very limited resources thanks Gary my
sense is if you have a view of adventure
and it's got to come complexity you have
to have some people or one person anyway
that is really full-time on this now he
said one and a half right whether that
person is paid or not paid is irrelevant
things but you you you if everybody's a
part-timer I don't see how anything I
don't see how you get it done because
it's somebody's always going to be
looking at their watch but in terms of I
got to go and what and and you're you're
not it's going to be hard to raise money
that way the other side of it just is
bad where you take the money you raise
and you pay you pay to people that are
average it to be there all the time and
now you've now you've got you got your
energy level for the others goes I don't
know all the details but I was always
from afar when I became aware of what
you were doing here was so impressed
that you guys were able to do so much
when you are so busy being CEO one of
the biggest obviously I don't know who
was full-time underneath or what are the
first things first things we did is I
went out to recruited a director an
executive director and I got a very
attractive guy who had been in
not-for-profit world for a long time if
with the cancer or leukemia and and he
had a good personality and I knew that
we could get him we tried to meld
different these these groups together
you need somebody that's going to be
full-time on that issue not part-time
and he was very helpful we were able to
pull together three different pair
driven organizations with very few
full-time people and and but we had to
every time we got to the scale I had to
have somebody full-time in there so
anything and Kim listen I was a drag on
the cross it was just Kim listen word
we're not competing and you know I'm
never tone-deaf we're not confused that
the air cover and the brand equity and
the place where Bob was in his career is
different than this organization and
that's always quite important I think
the thing to really think about though
is get that word quickly out of the
equation unless you have a miracle
situation where some art installation or
art moment becomes so culturally
relevant that everybody becomes aware
and wants to donate aka the ice bucket
challenge people want to be cynical
about that the data is very real they
were incredible
very real they had a moment but that's a
virality that comes around once in a
generation and so we need to be much
more practical in that those wanted to
have people and they're incredible I
would like to think look I think anybody
who devotes their careers or their and
all their time to a non-profit are so
passionate about that that they can be
patient over five to seven to 12 year
window hey Gary its carrier with
survivor radio daughter we're online
radio station theme for the cancer
community
I go to provide both insight and
monetary support for incidentals and
cancer patients all around the world
we're fairly new nonprofit with limited
resources so how do we grow both our
listenership and funding in 2016 what
platform should we be doing this on
we're trying to grow both so looking
forward to any answers man thanks and I
notice in the copy he says the older
demo carrier I would tell you Facebook
groups I'm obsessed with Facebook group
virality I would go in search Facebook
look for groups whether it's cancer
support groups or just you know you know
a million you know people that are
passionate or or have vibes in that
environment or just even general you
know medical or different groups of that
nature and literally email the admin
which you can do in those environments
try to join them and see if those groups
can bring some awareness in the
beginning you have to ask when you have
nothing else when you don't have dollars
you have you have your creativity and
you have your grit and you so you have
to ask and so I think whether it's
influencers I mean look you just did it
here you asked on Twitter you followed
what we're doing now 50,000 people in a
week will see this you're gonna be
linked up in here Stefan let's link up
all the organizations because I want to
make sure everybody clicks and finds out
about them and so in the same way that
you asked and you took a shot here and
guess what now hundreds of other people
took a shot and didn't get on today's
show won't get the exposure that's just
the way the game works and so I think
Facebook groups know for the older demo
is for is actually a very very
intriguing play any other thoughts from
your standpoint on things that you've
seen outside of your own ecosystem where
you had of equity Bob things that you've
watched from afar or have watched over
the last 30 40 50 years of seeing things
grow from not having any leverage in the
beginning and then hacking their way or
people that were able to get to you
through your career that had no you know
relationship or anything but just
reached out to you like and you know I
I'm thinking of a friend who reached out
them alone and a bunch of other Titans
and media and actually got to spend a
day with most of them because most I'm
actually just said yes well one of the
offer a comment here that it's probably
not directly on that point but something
has been bothering me for a year or so
people come to me and they ask me you
know how do I get into the business
where throw but I think you first you
you you want to you want to look at
yourself and decide what kinds of things
you really want to be associated with
and you've got to kind of make some
decisions you just can't be dragging 15
different ideas you've got to make some
decision but given the given the
situation today especially with the
internet the best thing you can do when
you're starting out is to get in the
technical side of the business learn
whatever you can on the technical side
of the business what you're doing here
sit with a camera when you're picking up
information how do you use the internet
from a standpoint of the technical part
you become very valuable to other people
and whether it's an odd forum especially
a not-for-profit where everybody wants
to do OK they want to do Facebook groups
and so forth how many people know how to
do that easily and and if you if you get
if you really get comfortable in these
areas then you can be very
useful and much in demand and then you
become a practitioner go figure actually
have a skill go figure
and you check you keep learning once
she's once you're in here you're
learning and learning more so you don't
have to I don't have to call up Ahmed
every minute to figure out why I can't
why I can't do this or that and the
other thing it make it kills me you know
and and but if you're comfortable with
it it's you're building a basis that's
going to be very attractive whether it's
for-profit or not-for-profit and you can
really help people and that's what
that's people looking to hire people are
gonna hundred percent Bob as we're
wrapping up the show any last thoughts
and then it's customary when somebody's
on the show for them to get to ask the
entire community a question of the day
and then given the context of the show
anything any requests for me and the
vaynernation that can be beneficial a
request of the day a little bit new well
I guess my request is that since my my
real charity is Autism Speaks and we're
all around the country and we represent
- we represent people with autism and
family with autism and our our website
is on all the time we're on Facebook or
on Twitter but our website has been our
primary method of communicating with
people so if you have it via email as
well yes but if you have you have issues
your questions you want to be part of it
and you know something that could be
helpful please go there and and and and
and make yourself known
everybody will be happy to be too happy
to meet you or happy yeah and it's very
local because there's there's not a
large community in the country that
we're not active in fantastic so we'll
link that up we'll make that linkable
stuff on let's make sure we get that all
right
and what about Baba a question of the
day it's gonna be you know again could
be a business contextual question the
NGO space we can talk about the jet you
can ask a Jets question if anything and
then with any any kind of a question of
the day that you want to ask the
vaynernation
or you know let me know as I'll get I
guess this is a kind of a general one
yeah one of the things that appears that
we're it's like personalized medicine
we're now doing personalized video and
since it's more and more people want to
control what we're that why
where they use video they have the tools
now the technical tools are there to do
it and and there is a potential that
that may get so far but you that also
distance you from other people if you're
watching video and you're picking it out
it personally and if you're not
connecting to other people you're
getting you're getting more of a loner
situation are you scared about what
technology is doing Bob I'm not scared
no I'm I'm just worried that people will
want this are going to do it but they're
going to realize at some point that
they're not getting enough social
connection if they're just doing
personal video if they're because
everything's going to be available
everything it's it's a it's only a
fraction of what's available today those
are may a lot more and you're going to
be able to you you just it video you're
eating up a lot of time and if you're
not communicating with anybody else in
that process you're I don't know I don't
know where that goes well but you know I
think you know this because I've been
very fascinated by all right I'm curious
if you know that exchanging data is
different cuz you can change it with
somebody well I think you can also look
at the argument the other way Bob right
which is that in 1947 without these
tools if my cousin lived in st. Louis I
maybe was not communicating with that
person at all or through the written
word or we can go back and read all the
things that were said about the
telephone and how it was gonna destroy
communication but I think I think the
interesting part of that question is it
a negative or is it a positive right I
don't know what it is I just know it's a
different it's it's different and I you
know it's maybe we're going to be more
of more into the mode of abusing the
tools of the only lasting 15 minutes or
20 minutes or 30 minutes and maybe
that's the one of course that's the
fastest-growing of all the apps but
maybe that's the way are you a big
snapchat enthusiast I'm not but I'm yeah
try to figure out why I'm good I like
that because it allows you to clear your
mind about it you don't have to carry
around this list of things you've set up
for the last you know 10 years here you
can you can start every day fresh I mean
look I think we're living look we're
living through and I it's an evolution I
mean you know again as being somebody
who's lived a little bit longer than the
this room you remember things where
literally people said Elvis Presley was
the devil cuz he shook his hips I don't
know if you've seen what the kids do now
but it's a little bit more aggressive
than how good old Elvis brought it right
and and when you look at what people
said I mean about the telephone or what
listen wait a minute I'm missing a big
opportunity here many people said 36
channels on television was gonna ruin
the kids because they're gonna have too
much information or what I grew up with
which was I don't know if you know this
but Atari and Nintendo we're gonna ruin
me and so I think the one thing on this
issue that I think is very curious as I
find the younger generation to actually
be more social not less yes maybe us
older folks me included everybody 40 and
above that didn't grow up with this as
kids may look at them as less social but
I would argue that they're just being
social in a different way all right I
can stick my real focus is his video his
video a help or is it is it an objective
or is it just an aid in the
communication oh well I think I'm
curious to see what everybody has to say
my friend thank you thank you for me on
the shank you very much woody well it
was a lot of fun you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
[Music]